oh my God
hairdos and don'ts of Olympic gold
medalists
oh my God is that Dorothy Hamill she's a
virgin
speaking of um
you know those girls at school who do it
like all the time yeah
all right is it just me or do they seem
more relaxed
hi
and what were you guys doing we're
talking about sex
come on Fez chicks don't talk about sex
man it's dirty
we do
involves Michael Kelso my dream boat oh
great now we have to talk about Jackie
and Kelso's sex life this is my worst
nightmare
I know I was surprised too
hey Daddy you want to go to my house
you know what okay
just so you know Donna when I finally
decide to do with Michael I have the
whole thing planned out
first I'll be wearing a very sexy Renoir
don't you mean penoir
yeah okay whatever stop ruining this
Donna
okay
and then
there'll be candles everywhere
[Music]
one awesome
there'll be a gigantic Banner
and then Michael will come in
the wind will be blowing
the night of our lives so
if you have it all planned out
why are you uh
why are you still waiting
I want it to be really really special
well I mean how could it not with a
gigantic Banner exactly
foreign
oh thank God you're home
I was driving a stolen car and I got
arrested
oh Michael this is just like the book
prisoner of love but Cliff the record
gets sweet motorcycle mechanic was
thrown into jail
and then he's true love Tasha was forced
to be a slave but for this really rich
mean guy Jackie I'm not kidding around
I'm really in jail
oh my God are you okay
yeah I guess
but I'm a little cold
slowly in the joint Jackie
that you're really in jail
that would really suck
yes it would Michael and I promise the
minute you get out of prison I'm gonna
prove my love to you
cool thanks
Michael do you even know what I'm saying
to you yeah
no
we're gonna make love you idiot
all right
[Applause]
you two have a nice little talk oh yeah
you know what's funny what nothing
because you forgot to ask her for help
you
[Music]
Michael you've been
oh my God
you don't know what it's like on the
inside Jackie
damn those police oh no it was high but
he really frogged me
oh
it's Jackie
okay so let's do this thing oh this is
so perfect I didn't even miss the the
pen war the pirate shirt of the Wind
what about the banner
it's okay
the important thing is
I'm here with you
and I'm prepared to give myself to you
body mind and soul
Michael this is going to be the most
magical night of our lives
oh yeah and one more thing
my parents are the amp so I'm only have
like 15 minutes
[Music]
foreign